[Applaudissements]
sujet du christ si quelqu'un me plaît je
me transforme en tchat
ok c'est dans tu parles pendant une
heure d'interview picard qui a éclaté
juste un truc et vous faites comment la
chatte n'étaient pas sages vous c'est
comme ça là c'est le chablaisien j'aurai
donc vous et vous vous faites quoi vu
jennifer je vais sortir
c'est bête
c'est bête parce que je voulais reparler
de ma déclaration d' album de jenifer
malheureusement je vais plus parler du
livre de patrick politique je sors fuite
les vannes et hémisphère asseyez vous
sur le fauteuil
attention emprunt jennifer jennifer ce
qui me prend qu'elle doit sceller vous
sur le volet ce que j'ai une très très
belle surprise qu est ce que vous savez
est ce que vous savez qu'ils sont océane
brunel maylis et anaïs ce sont des gens
qui comptent beaucoup pour vous
d'univers d'accord est ce que vous savez
de qui il s'agit
océane brunel maidi sadat x brunel ça ne
fait rien je connais les autres prénoms
des personnages dit vous ne les
connaissez pas vraiment il rêvait de
vous voir en vrai font partie d'une
association qui nous tient énormément à
coeur dans touche pas à mon poste et
dont vous êtes la marraine le refuge
exactement
merci de les accueillir ils sont venus
avec olivier serge et aurélie qui sont
bénévoles auraient fui
[Applaudissements]
c'est
façon qu'il est maintenant
alors attention mettez vous derrière
jennifer les chéris je sais que vous
êtes content de la boîte